hello grammarians today i want to talk
about ending sentences with prepositions
and i want to tell you straight up it is
totally okay like it is perfectly
grammatically correct and sensible and
fine to end sentences with prepositions
in english
and if you don't know what i mean that's
fine
um let me let me throw out some examples
like it's a crazy world we live in for
example is a sentence that ends in in
which is a preposition and for years for
hundreds of years there have been people
language authorities that have been
telling you it's not okay to end a
sentence with a preposition let me tell
you by the power vested in me it is
totally okay this is one of those
language superstitions that will not die
taking away the terminal preposition
takes away sentences like that's not
behavior i'll put up with and in fact
some of you have maybe heard the
statement that is supposedly attributed
to uh
winston churchill where he says um that
is something with which up i will not
put which kind of emphasizes how clunky
that is you know
if that's supposed to be formal high
language it sounds
really inarticulate not a fan
this is ultimately a question not of
grammar but of style
because there's nothing there's nothing
about it's a crazy world we live in that
doesn't make sense that doesn't function
as a sentence
indeed there's nothing grammatically
incorrect with you know this is behavior
with which up i will not put it's just
needlessly verbose and twisting back on
itself
for the sake of avoiding something that
doesn't need to be avoided
we can trace all of this back to robert
loth a man who was the bishop of london
during part of the 18th century and he
wrote about uh terminal prepositions in
his 1762
short introduction to english grammar
which reads in part quote this is an
idiom which our language is strongly
inclined to it prevails in common
conversation and suits very well with
the familiar style in writing but the
placing of the preposition before the
relative is more graceful and agrees
much better with the solemn and elevated
style but
bishop loath may i direct your attention
to this part of your statement this is
an idiom which our language is strongly
inclined to even when bishop loath is
using what he calls this solemn and
elevated style he himself cannot avoid
ending a clause boom with a preposition
game set match sir
the question is why did loth have such a
b in his bonnet about prepositions at
the end of sentences and the answer can
be found in latin follow me over to the
next screen
here is the deal with latin in latin uh
prepositions have a very particular
function similar to how they work in
english
but let's let's break apart what the
word preposition
is in latin the word preposition comes
from pre-positio
which means placed before right or
placed before
because here's something cool about
latin
latin's word order rules are different
than english's word order rules i'll
explain
you know in english we have this
expression
to put the cart before the horse which
means to embark on a project before
you're really ready
and this is a very ancient expression in
fact
one that can be attested in latin
like so
ante
right okay so this is before the horse
the cart to put
here's the thing about prepositions in
latin is that in latin this ante before
always has to go
has to be positioned
before
the word is attached to so before the
horse
but
in latin you can rearrange this sentence
any way you like so you could say karum
and just because of the way latin works
because of its case endings and and
because of this prepositional
relationship we can always tell no
matter what order the words are in
how the sentence parts relate to one
another
or we could also switch it around
ponere karum ante equim right like it
could go in any order
as long as
ante was before ecua
now admittedly in english if you wanted
to end this with a preposition it would
still sound pretty awkward like the cart
is the thing that the horse is before
but it is still grammatical if you move
this thing if you move ante out of order
there's no way to tell what's going on
in the sentence
latin during the time that loth was
bishop of london was the language of
scholarship right
it was this language that enabled people
all over the european continent to
communicate with each other in a common
language of knowledge it was the
language of religion and philosophy
and all of that added up to make latin
really cool
and also very powerful
and because of the history of the
english language which basically entails
people in boats coming over the north
sea to beat the tar out of celts and
anglo-saxons and leave you know latin or
norse or french-shaped dents in their
language
english has this kind of
uncomfortable relationship with latin
english scholars
kind of had an inferiority complex and
so during the 17th and 18th century you
really see this move towards latinizing
english trying to make
english grammar behave more like latin
grammar
but english comes from a different
language heritage it's a germanic
language and that doesn't mean it's
better or worse than latin it just means
it's different and it behaves
differently we shouldn't try to
treat english as though it were anything
other than english
so if anyone ever tells you that you
can't end a sentence with a preposition
send them this page
or if you prefer you know where to send
them to
which which is here on khan academy
where you can learn anything
david out